welcome back to the 41st ever episode of
the iced coffee hour my name is andrej
and i have my two guests here graham
stefan and jack hi how you guys doing
how are you here
hey i got one question for you hey how
much have we made on the podcast so far
you guys made forty thousand five
hundred fifteen dollars and 54
cents fantastic yeah cool that was a
great introduction thanks so much for
coming on andre
hello you should your go-to line now is
wow wow amazing interest one we've had
but do it like dogecoin style much wow
well welcome no for those that don't
know you andre
thank you you have a youtube channel
you have it you're you're the las vegas
gram
right you have another personal finance
channel on youtube
way to insult your guests 1.2
3 million subscribers 1.3
congratulations and growing at a rapid
rate as well
it is rapid the rate is rapid is yeah
very rapid uh what are we talking about
here
we're gonna talk crypto today okay we're
gonna talk crypto we're gonna talk a
whole bunch of personal finance and
investing stuff
and then we're gonna be talking about us
hiring someone new to come join on the
team
i will not be applying you don't want
you don't want the job
you don't want the job man no
i'll apply all right but uh yeah so
welcome
thank you thank you for having me yeah
we were talking about ad revenue are we
comparing
yeah what's your to date revenue my to
date one
gosh do you want to like how do i send
you a screenshot or you just want to
yeah just take a screenshot sure
um i'll send it to you but really quick
you guys we have to thank backblaze for
sponsoring this episode
in this world we really only need four
things to survive food
water oxygen and access to data graham
and i collaborate to produce seven
videos a week we have more than
20 sd cards four cameras and files
flying
all over the place with so many moving
parts there's a ton of potential for
complications which is really costly
when you're in business
one time we lost an entire video that we
were going to post due to not backing up
footage fortunately backblaze exists for
this exact
reason backblaze is an amazing service
that allows for unlimited computer
backup for 30 days
and is only six dollars a month you can
back up any digital data from the newest
millennial money video to uncle phil's
family vacation photo album it's the
cloud you have access to these files
anywhere you have the internet is 30
days not long enough for you for an
extra two dollars a month you can
increase your retention history to a
whole year
visit backblaze.com iced coffee for a
free trial be sure to use that link
backblaze.com iced coffee so they know
where you came from and to continue to
support the show once again that is
backblaze.com
iced coffee protect yourself today thank
you backblaze and back to the podcast
but i think today
i'm going to officially break a million
i'm right today
today i'm at 997 000
set three hundred ninety four dollars
and fifty nine cents but i've been
averaging six to seven thousand a day on
rad revenue
holy crap congratulations thanks man
this calls for a celebration that's a
big milestone that's
huge to say you made a million dollars
in youtube and ad revenue that's insane
right wow
yeah but now here's the kicker is that i
bet most of that was in the last
year right 100 yeah yeah because well
let's see my 2020
oh man this doesn't give me a breakdown
for the years but yeah like my january
was 104
000 my february so far is 90 000. so
i guess yeah congratulations thank you
the irs
has entered the chat i love
really why we're doing this graham's an
insider agent
it's it's so funny because every time i
post about my income yeah
every single time so it's like the irs
or or they say california has just
entered the chat
well i don't even know how california is
letting you leave
we'll see i guess we'll find out i've
legitimately leaved i've
changed i've leave
[Laughter]
anyway congratulations thank you that's
really exciting
yeah what are you at right now on ad
revenue yeah
i think three something jesus it's uh
it's been wild so you've been on youtube
since
2017 or six years technically 2016
yeah because it started it was the day
after christmas
so december 26th is the first day i
started realistically with 2017.
uh yeah like january uh it was
lifetime wow three million
seven hundred and forty five thousand
six hundred and ninety seven dollars and
thirty did you still check that at all
graham
what do you mean the lifetime revenue uh
check it no rarely i like to see the
graph going up over time and uh
as long as as long as it's doing that
don't say yes
it's just going up i know i'm on the
right track so
anyway yeah crazy like that i can't
believe this is real like just sitting
here
and being able to say that out loud like
i know people watching this are probably
so desensitized to this because
everybody on the internet's a
millionaire but i don't take that for
granted like this is crazy
just to be able to like sit here and do
videos
and like that's crazy work without a
boss
like that what yeah that's insane that's
incredible
it's probably because you still live a
really modest life yeah it hasn't really
settled in yet
no i don't think it will because i don't
think i'll ever like live a crazy life
how long have you been in your current
place for in the one i'm renting yeah
five years five years a little over five
what's your rent your rent's like 1500
a month right 1400 split between three
people so 450 for each of us
wow and so you've kept the same 450 a
month apartment
yeah four five five years five years
yeah wow
yeah so i've been saving a lot of money
which is great uh
because there's a foreshadowing but
anyway
wow we'll have to see what that is but
you've been investing a lot of the money
lately in crypto i have yeah
got you into crypto um what's your total
portfolio right now you gotta be like
seven hundred dollars what's your
principal and what's the amount of
profit yeah i'll show you
so i know my principal is around a
hundred thousand dollars
so i'm gonna open up my block fica so i
buy my crypto off of gemini but i know
coinbase is
like equally as good right so if people
are using coinbase that one works too
they're honestly both
great um i wouldn't buy it on like
robinhood
because robinhood and all those free
brokerages they don't let you take your
coins off
so which which means you're kind of
buying a derivative
you're buying a promise from them which
is not what you want to do because the
whole idea of crypto is that you have
sovereignty over your money
and so by using these more expensive
crypto brokerages like a gemini or like
a coin base
you have the option to remove it and go
somewhere else which is you want that
freedom
so i use block fi um you could go to
block five dot com forward slash andre
you'll get up to 250 worth of free
bitcoin anyway
how do i get 250 worth of freebie how
much do i have what's the average
yeah you've got to deposit i don't know
what actually the amount is to get up to
250. it's got to be like 100
is it i don't know i don't think it's
that high yeah a lot of those bank
sign-up bonuses that i get like
get up to a thousand dollars on us yeah
look at it deposit a million
deposits it's like that was clickbait
like don't put that in the headline like
how many people are really
looking at an email okay 688
yes 688 thousand 740
so six almost seven thousand in interest
paid out
so i think the average interest rate
between because like after a certain
amount of bitcoin i think like after one
or two
maybe three the interest rate drops and
i'm guessing that they're not going to
have this kind of 8.6
interest rate forever it's as they
mature i'm sure it'll you know lower
but it's 8.6 on usdc which is the stable
coin
one for one um and yeah eight point six
percent interest but i'm making like
fifteen hundred dollars a month on
interest alone
three times your rent yeah three well
three times my rent yeah which is crazy
right so like
yeah i mean if you're going to keep your
crypto online you should
never keep it online unless you're
getting compensated for it that's like
the biggest tip
um because like most people that buy
crypto they always hold it
on the brokerage they bought you know
because like getting into the cold
storage stuff is like we could talk
about it but
it's so complicated people are just like
ah whatever i'll keep it on coinbase or
robinhood or wherever
and what sucks is like they're taking
the risk because if those brokers just
get hacked
your coins are gone and you can like you
hope that that company will give you
your money back
but in the case that it doesn't that
would suck so if you're going to take
that risk
you should be getting paid interest you
might as well
unless you don't want to take the risk
then you should take it you know offline
to like cold storage
i use like the ledger nano but i know
there's a ton of companies out there
what do you think the likelihood is
though that one of those brokerages gets
hacked
i would imagine that would be like i
feel like it's inevitable for coinbase
to get hacked let's say that's got to be
a huge thing and you know if there's a
hack they're not just taking like a
million dollars and also is there any
insurance on coin bases yeah they're all
insured for sure
i don't know like what what's up by what
it's not like
lloyd bank or something i'm not sure
which which entrance they use but it's
insured probably up to
maybe more than 100 million dollars i
know all of them that's like pretty much
at minimum
um they use a lot of insurance but even
at 100 billion that's kind of a drop in
the bucket
right when their custody's billions of
dollars i'm almost thinking that if
there is a hack
let's say if coinbase someone's going in
and taking everything yeah
so like that would completely crash the
crypto market
if a coin base was to get hacked it
probably would because of the fear
which kind of sucks because that doesn't
mean the blockchain is hacked it just
means that company was
same thing that happened to mount gox
remember yeah yeah if you guys remember
or don't remember it yeah mount gox was
basically this website that
was a front for magic the gathering
originally
and so the ceo mark carpolis the guy who
originally owned it he was a magic the
gathering
guy and then somehow they like converted
their website to a bitcoin
custodial like brokerage service and
because they didn't have their security
right
because they were like a you know
trading card website
they got hacked and that was like
probably like the biggest scandal in all
of bitcoin was
was that and how much did that affect
the price of bitcoin oh it crashed it it
crashed like
90 percent right yeah how long ago was
that
i think 2012 yeah yeah something like
that
yeah somewhere around there and i don't
know if that thing has been resolved yet
i think people are still waiting to get
pa
to get their money back but they will
but would they get the money back
no it was worth nothing then no it won't
they won't they won't
i don't think they will i don't think
they're going to get their millions of
dollars back because
people have thousands of bitcoins that's
not going to happen they would pay out
what it was worth back then most
likely which was like i don't know what
it was
yeah then it was like 300 bucks yeah
sure
because they probably would have held
like today 100 or at least until it
appreciated quite a bit for sure
yeah no it's crazy but but speaking of
those 90 crashes i don't think we'll
we'll see one anytime soon right because
like how much money has entered the
crypto sphere now
we're almost at a trillion dollar market
cap so
for crypto whales like we've had before
to like influence the price 90
is gonna take so much money you're gonna
have like
companies from the s p 500 that need to
collude together
to manipulate the price to the extent
that it used to be manipulated when it
was like a 100 billion dollar market cap
so i don't think we'll see that again
but it's a possibility
so i'm not writing it off but we could
crash again but it seems like at this
point in time the support level is like
30 000
but it's bitcoin so who knows it could
go down to 15 000 include 10 000
tomorrow we don't know
we don't know what's the catalyst but
that's the downside the upside though is
there's so many catalysts still
like today i made a video about you know
apple entering the crypto sphere
mastercard
venmo like it's crazy what's going on
miami became the first municipality of
the first city
that started integrating bitcoin into
its city so now
people are going to be able to pay their
city fines and
taxes with bitcoin and they'll be able
to get a portion of their salary be paid
out in bitcoin too
my understanding though bitcoin is
horrible in terms of
moving it from one person to another
yeah as as a currency it's not there yet
because of what's called the scaling
issue
so i want to talk about that we did a
really complicated thing you explain it
yeah so here's the thing with bitcoin
and i'm not i'm not i'm just going to
preface this with saying like i'm not
the best person to explain it
so just explain it in the way that i
understand it but basically with bitcoin
um there's kind of like a bottleneck
meaning that if you and i are going to
use bitcoin the way that it works is
like
there is these blocks right and they're
one megabyte inside so you can kind of
think of like a rubik's cube
and inside this rubik's cube are coins
or
transactions so anytime i send you a
bitcoin or you send me a bitcoin
those transactions get sent to this
block
now this rubik's cube needs to be solved
in order to have these rewards be
distributed
amongst the people who are solving them
so those are the miners
they use their computing power to
basically solve these blocks
and then get rewarded for doing so
that's the incentive
so the other analogy to this are these
these miners are also like bus drivers
so every 10 minutes this bus arrives
to take their transactions and they go
and that means that
once this block is confirmed or solved
our transactions get confirmed right
that's the way it works are you with me
so far
jack does not look like i don't
understand what do you mean the
transactions get confirmed it's just
when the bus leaves right
yes so what i mean by that is this okay
i got it yeah oh
no no so what it means is this so
whenever we use something like visa or
whatever mastercard our transactions are
confirmed
instantaneously on the back end they
don't
they're it's a little bit more
complicated but to us the users it's
confirmed instantaneously
that makes it a good currency quote
unquote like a good system to transact
because
it's instantaneous right whereas bitcoin
you have to wait at on average 10
minutes for your
transaction to be confirmed which sucks
because if i'm shopping for something
and if i'm
whatever scanning my debit card i can't
wait for 10 minutes for the merchant to
be like okay cool
transactions is through here's the
product that's that's
doesn't work so that's the scaling
problem it's like how do we scale
bitcoin
to include more transactions to be
confirmed quicker aka and this analogy
the
how do we get more buses to arrive
quicker and not every 10 minutes
you can't that was how bitcoin was
designed it was designed to be
specifically that way
so it means it's slow and clunky and
expensive because
the more popular bitcoin becomes the
more the price goes up
then it means the more people are
competing so if you think about the bus
analogy you think of the bus stop that's
called the mempool
so the bus stop has its own name that's
the mempool anytime we send transactions
to each other
our transactions get first sent to the
mempool which is the bus stop
anytime this bus arrives think of it
like
we have to bid against one another to be
included on the bus
so we compete by sending with our
transactions a minor
fee it's not free to just get your
transaction included in the block you
have to pay a fee
the fee is nominal it's very small right
but the more expensive bitcoin becomes
the more you are paying and the more
people are using bitcoin the more
popular it becomes
it becomes outrageously expensive to the
point where if i want to send you a
dollar
i have to bribe the bus driver a hundred
dollars to get included in the
transaction
which sucks like that's i don't want to
send a dollar and spend a hundred
dollars just to do that
so that's where we hit the wall of the
scaling solution
or the scaling problem but first we have
to thank our amazing sponsor vessy guys
vessies are absolutely amazing they are
literally all graham and i wear now for
a multitude of reasons
first off they're incredibly comfortable
not only can i wear them for long walks
outside
but i actually use them as slippers too
i just fold the back down and boom
now i'm ready to relax second off
they're actually waterproof
not just resistant i know for a fact i
can count on my vessies to keep my feet
dry
in any given circumstance finally my
vessies are super cool and stylish i
feel confident wearing my vessies to any
occasion i can dress up dress down or
just dress
casual it's an all-in-one shoe another
thing that i love about my vessies is
that they are super cost effective
because shoes wear out so quickly the
average person spends
419 dollars per year on footwear we of
course know that's outrageous
and with vessy's all you need is one
pair and that will easily last you a
year
and for every occasion you can cut your
footwear bill down drastically and save
some money on the side for some
lucrative dogecoin investments
so please guys visit vessie.com iced
coffee and get 25
off your pair of vessies trust me you
will love these things support this
podcast by visiting vessie.com
iced coffee or use code iced coffee at
checkout once again
25 off your pair of shoes thank you so
much vessy for sponsoring this episode
and back to the podcast
i noticed that when i was buying bitcoin
on coinbase
the fees were outrageous like it was a
lot that's when you do a market order
you never do them are we doing market
orders no it has nothing to do with
marketing
base they have their own like back end
system which
um i forget what coin basis it's called
playbase wasn't bad at all
each of these big brokerages they have
like their back end systems which so
what we see in the front end are like
the market
whatever you could place a limit order
on them too but you're still going to
pay the fees
if you want to pay less fees you have to
use their like
pro software which i think is free yeah
that's what i do i have points
as well but they also no i don't know if
they still have fees
they do they do it's a lot more
flexible but that's not the problem the
problem is not the software the problem
is
when bitcoin is really popular even that
software you're still going to be paying
insane amounts of money but
the catch with bitcoin is you don't have
to attach a fee
to the transaction so if you don't want
to pay the bus driver you will
eventually be included on the bus
provided that there's not that many
people in the mempool waiting to get
included as well
because like what could happen is you
could send a transaction
not pay a fee but then get included like
a week later
or a month later like imagine you bought
something and you're like waiting for a
month
so so that that problem has been with
bitcoin since the beginning of time
and bitcoin has forked which is like
where it's split
and people have different like protocols
and different solutions for their vision
of what bitcoin should be of how it can
scale
which is why you hear all the time
people are like cardano's better
ethereum's better whatever's better is
because
it's it's a better form of currency
because it's confirmed quicker or
whatever it is
so why are people trying to use bitcoin
as a currency
what would be the purpose of accepting
taxes in bitcoin
besides just the hype of this being like
we need to pay taxes with bitcoin
right yeah there isn't any if you're if
not like if you're not like a money nerd
it doesn't make any sense to which is
why i believe in 2017
bitcoin finally kind of figured out the
narrative of what it was meant to be
because for the longest time the crypto
community had a war like an internal
war with each other one side of people
wanted it to be a currency
and the other side wanted to be a store
of value
and so for the first time in 2017 that's
when i
like really saw the crypto sphere like
take off in 2017 was bitcoin
split into two it was bitcoin core at
the time i believe it was just bitcoin
and bitcoin cash i don't know if you've
heard of bitcoin cash you've heard of
that one
and that was the first like original
fork that's split
and its ethos was let's use bitcoin as a
currency
so the difference between those two and
this is something most people don't even
like they don't know they don't go that
far in the research
is that bitcoin cash has a different
scaling solution
so so here's so now you've understood
the problem right hopefully like you
understand it's slow it's clunky there's
two main solutions to this problem
that people are doing it's either scale
on
chain on the blockchain or scale off
chain
off the block chain so there's these are
the two differences
on chain means let's change the base
protocol of what bitcoin was meant to be
so let's change the block size from one
megabyte to i don't know 10 megabytes
right that way we can have more people
be included in the bus because the bus
you're just literally increasing the bus
size
you're like now we can fit more people
in so now it becomes cheaper to get on
um and the problem that those guys
encountered from the other half of the
bitcoin community is like
you can't download the way that bitcoin
works is like this is public ledger
right
so in order for you to download this
public ledger it has to be small enough
to download
but if the blocks get too big and
there's too many transactions
the history of the whole blockchain
becomes so large
you literally need to become a
corporation just to be able to handle
the size to download it to verify it for
yourself
does that make sense so like it becomes
impossible for the
individual who lives in a basement or
wherever
to like participate in the network so
that
got a lot of pushback so bitcoin cash
split off
and their solution was to scale on the
blockchain
their argument against it was we have
moore's law
right so every how many years two years
the technology capacity like doubles
like computers get better every i think
it was two years and maybe i'm wrong
and so they're saying like if we look
back like sd cards that were like
five megabyte were like 300 10 years ago
but now that we have more space it's
cheaper eventually we'll catch up and
it's not a huge deal
so they split up and that's what
happened the bitcoin
main bitcoin that we see now that's 50
000
roughly is is going to eventually scale
what's called
off chain so not on chain but off chain
uh with systems called lightning or
liquid
there's like different protocols of
doing it and we can go into that if you
want too this is complicated but it gets
insanely into the weeds i do just want
to note one thing really quickly
one of the reasons why a lot of
businesses do want to accept bitcoin is
because
sometimes it's difficult to be accepted
by payment processors
and oh and that's why they use it on
like the the dark web
and stuff like that is because you can't
get approved by stripe
or by you know those types of guys so
you just send a bitcoin wallet
that makes sense so if you saw today
apple
um started integrating it with bitpay if
you i don't know if you guys are
familiar with bitpay
bitpay uses i believe the mastercard
network so
bitpay was a company that's kind of like
the middleman they have their own debit
card so you get a debit card
you can load your bitcoin onto that and
then anywhere that accepts bitpay you
can
pay using your bitcoin but is that
instantaneous it's instantaneous okay
because they're kind of the middlemen
that facilitate the whole transaction so
they take on the risk
and they convert everything on the fly
so they provide the liquidity
but the problem is is like very few
stores actually accept bitpay like it
was like what the hell's bitcoin right
nobody's heard of that so apple finally
teamed up with bitpay or
i don't know to like to what degree they
teamed up but now you can put your bid
pay debit cards on to apple pay which
means that you can now actually spend
your bitcoin anywhere apple pay is
accepted
i just feel like that would create a tax
nightmare to go and like buy let's say a
car with bitcoin and then you have to
figure out
what's going to be the capital gains on
that and then you're going to have to
pay taxes
on an asset that you were holding yeah
that used to be a huge problem a couple
years ago it's not anymore
there's like automated tax websites
where you can just give
what's like custodial permission to look
at your
balances like your buys and your cells
and they calculate all of that stuff for
you and you just get a print out and you
can give it to your tax person wouldn't
that be complicated let's say i'm dollar
cost to averaging like every week
yeah over years right wouldn't that just
be just a lot of
calculating to do on that for your taxes
if you do it manually maybe
but why would you do it manually you
could just go to those websites and they
plug it in
everything for you it's automatic yeah
it's amazing i use it yeah so i'm going
to use it this year maybe i'll make a
video about it at some point but
it in theory it's really easy you just i
gave it permission and now it tracks all
of my buys all of my sales
so it gives me the net you know whatever
it is my net profit
and then i give it to my tax person and
then calculate it uh how did you get
into crypto
oh i bought a drone
i bought a drone for like i i actually
found bitcoin in 2012.
i was like dude this stuff is so cool
it's a hundred dollars but it's going to
multiply to 200.
what made you think it was going to
multiply to 300 because i read about it
there's like people that are like
becoming millionaires because they put
in some stupid amount of money
and i was like i want to do that that's
the same thing with the stock market
yeah for sure yeah but it was like the
new hot kid on the block it was like
what is bitcoin sure
were you talking about it with your
friends and stuff like that was just
self-discovery i was but at the time you
couldn't buy it from like the
traditional
places that you could today and you
couldn't hold it anywhere you couldn't
store it anywhere
so i like the technolo that technology
was so far behind that i was like how do
you
i don't get this stuff so i i ignored it
until 2014 when
coinbase became a thing i bought it
there
held on to it for like a year and i was
like man it's not multiplying
[Music]
so i i bought in at 600 a coin i spent
like a couple grand
yeah and then i sold it for i bought a
drone i was like i want to buy a drone
the dji like phantom
3 was at the time good job i was like
dude there's such a sick drone i was
like i don't want to spend money i was
like
oh i had that one bitcoin thing it's
like collecting dust
my three thousand dollar investment was
fifteen hundred dollars
and i was like you know what i just
wanna get rid of it so i got rid of it
i bought the drone for fifteen hundred
dollars three bit
six bitcoin that i spent basically and
yeah those six bitcoin today would be
worth three hundred grand
on a drone that cost a thousand dollars
let me guess as soon as you bought the
drone
bitcoin just turned around that was the
jack symptom
[Laughter]
the jack symptom is every time jack buys
a stock
it goes down immediately afterwards and
so jack and i are sitting next to each
other and jack looks over at my computer
he's like
oh graham you're buying a stock and i'm
like yeah and i turn my computer away
because i know it's going to go down as
soon as he buys it it's like well i'm
going to buy it too
i'm like no don't buy in because as soon
as you do it's going to go down in price
he's like no i'm going to blow i'm going
to buy in and we're literally looking at
the chart
and it starts ticking down it's just
like as i'm like
hovering over the buy button this stock
is just going down i imagine there's
like somebody behind the scenes who's
looking and they're like all right
jack's buying all right like
yeah he's getting close yeah oh all
right he's sold he sold it safely
you know what's funny is that he's like
all right i'm not gonna buy it and he
takes his phone and puts it down
and you start going back up immediately
afterwards
and then and then i buy and it keeps
going up and then and then
you were trying to actually hide from me
yeah
i'm not kidding i was like did you just
buy because i was sitting next to him
when i
saw him like in this brokerage or
whatever i was like did you just
probably like no no no i didn't buy i
didn't buy
and i like look over and i see that he
bought so he just lied to me
and then i buy it and it goes down and i
lost a lot of money
and now i've realized the loss of like
eight hundred dollars was the
moment he bought it started going down
like the second
like that's not coincidence so just do
the opposite of what jack does always
and yes
basically do really well yeah so yeah
yeah so that's why
now if i buy something i just don't tell
jack yeah don't ever tell people yeah
nobody don't communicate with jack about
investing ever
i've been having a lot of fun though
watching the price of bitcoin
crazy how much has your initial
investment appreciated uh so
i originally got in i think it was like
one because i dollar cost average i
think
total i invest like 115 and i think
that's like 160 something
wow and that's in like a month and a
half that's crazy and
i bought in i think somewhat high like i
was buying in
at basically the peak of a
month and i remember yeah and that was
in the low 30s
and then ethereum was 1100 bucks
like 11 11.50 and i remember too
it goes to show you like sometimes the
little details don't matter but i had
like i think it was like 10 grand i want
to put in ethereum
and so i put my limited order in at like
11 85 or something like that it was
straight at like 12. okay
and i'm sitting there for like 20
minutes and it doesn't hit it goes like
you know it's just like a few dollars
away and i'm sitting there like wasting
yeah all this time just like it's not
gonna hit it's not gonna hit it doesn't
hit
i'm like ah screw it should i leave it
no you know what i'm just gonna buy it
at the price so i paid the market
price yeah 1200 bucks uh that's what
happened to me with apple
yeah i did a video like my dividend
video and i was like cool i'm gonna set
a limit order
for apple i put i put in like ten
thousand dollars at a just a
dollar below like actually at the market
price that day
the next day i'm like yeah it'll it'll
trigger it never did
yeah you know bit like apples last like
two weeks ago
oh yeah i feel so like yeah frustrated
about that but but the bitcoin thing
it's crazy because that drone that's
that
like what happened then is what taught
me to like look closer
because whenever we talk about bitcoin
everyone's like ah they like roll their
eyes like oh yeah
tell me more about how your friend made
millions of dollars of bitcoin we don't
care
you know but it's like once this stuff
happens you start to like
look into it deeper you're like what is
it really like why does it have value
like
i don't get it like what is it and that
scenario with the drone really what
like triggered me to learn about the
monetary
system and like how deep the rabbit hole
goes and you
and once you get like what it is then
you're like
i'm never gonna like sell this wow
that's a convincing argument it becomes
so different once you look beyond the
price action
which i think is what you had a lot of
trouble with the beginning because you
kind of dismissed it
as like this like just price like i
don't say like ponzi but like okay cool
it's a beanie baby
like okay yeah you're gonna make
millions but it's gonna crash it's
stupid
because i like that we all think that
like because you look at the price
action and it doesn't make any sense
but if you take the time to learn why it
has value
um then it just changes the game hey
graham i don't mean to change the
subject but have you heard of
privacy.com
of course man how could i not well right
but i'm worried that some of our viewers
haven't heard about this well we gotta
fix this
right now give it to him jack how about
this you guys i'll make a bet with you
if you aren't already using this product
i bet you've never heard of it because
there is literally no
reason why you shouldn't be using
privacy.com like everyone i need to pay
for things
and i'm uncomfortable with the idea that
so many people have access to my credit
card information luckily privacy.com
solves this problem so that i will never
have to deal with this again
let me break this down for you it works
like this instead of handing out my
credit card to everyone i can link my
credit card to one of privacy's virtual
cards
i can then pay for things using their
card instead of my own
that's not even the best part these
privacy cards have massive perks such as
being able to pause the card instantly
set transaction limits and cancel with
the click of a button
this protects you from ever having to
worry about your card ending up in the
wrong hands plus if you go with the
privacy pro plan
you actually get one percent cash back
this is outside of any rewards you will
receive from your real card people are
actually
making money with this plan the cash
back is super nice
i trust privacy so much that the card in
the graphic you just saw moments ago
is actually one of my privacy credit
cards directly tied to my real primary
credit card it also has ten dollars of
single use credit on it first come first
serve
feel free to get yourself a coffee on me
do yourself a favor and sign up for
privacy.com there are literally so many
perks i cannot cover them all
on top of everything you will receive a
five dollar credit by clicking the link
below or heading to privacy.com
ich trust me you do not want to miss out
this is privacy.com
ich thank you so much privacy for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast
so you're still buying in today i
haven't bought in today
but i'd i will i'll average in when i
feel like it's it's time to
um when would you say it's time to i
like
yeah when it's time um when it hits a
certain price
i'm still like doing research to figure
out what it is i don't think it's going
to hit 30 000 again
anytime soon it will probably eventually
but i like i need to get rid of my
initial principal value
because that's what i always tell people
i'm like whenever you invest in like
quadruples in price which for me it's
like 6x by now from 100 grand
um but i've been buying since 2014 is
like you need to just sell what you
invested right because the rest is play
money so if you lose it who cares
but now it's like i'm just terrified
that a catalyst is around the corner
we're going to get like a bitcoin etf
and i'm just like like or i'm like maybe
i can sell bitcoin or like now that
elon's gone why would you sell it
why would i say you don't need the money
right now no you don't need it that's
true but i'm just saying unless you need
the money don't sell
for sure for sure i'm just saying like
for the principal value of it like the
principal equity just
just to sell it and be like cool like i
made my money oh you're gonna have the
principal value
anyway unless it crashes 90 you're still
going to have it no matter what
there's no point in selling that's what
i was thinking about but i'm like oh i
really want to buy a tesla and i
put it on my instagram i was like if
elon ever starts accepting bitcoin i'm
totally going to buy a tesla would you
actually
no i thought about i'm like i'm not
about to give up an appreciating asset
for a depreciating one like that isn't
it
i don't understand why a lot of like
businesses are accepting bitcoin as
point when it's
so volatile hype it's not because of
hype it's because everybody
like just it's that hedge fund money
problem where it's like imagine being
the hedge fund that's like
you know you're making money for your
customers and they're like hey this year
you made 10
for us how come like kathy wood made 300
what are you gonna say like you're a
hedge fund manager you're like uh uh
because i don't have bitcoin in my
portfolio
you know they have to have a solution
for bitcoin like what is our bitcoin
strategy is like a
phrase that's like you need a you need a
an answer to it
and so it's like it forces everybody to
enter
not even for the hype of it but when
your customer asks you what is like
what's our game plan you got to be able
to say well we got one percent exposure
or whatever like we accept it if you
want it
you need to have these bridges built if
you don't customers leave and go
somewhere else where they are
but do they just sell the bitcoin as
soon as they receive it as payment
no some do some don't um i don't know i
feel like it's so inefficient
to charge for bitcoin like if i'm a
grocery store
i'm saying i accept bitcoin just because
i know that
maybe one customer out of a thousand
might actually pay with bitcoin but
it gets more attention like oh look at
the grocery store that accepted bitcoin
yeah i see right now it cannot exist as
a currency because of the volatility
right
but that's the function of good money
right now good money which is bitcoin is
sucking up like the vacuum
the dyson sphere ah stupid reference if
you watch the logan paul
thing but anyway it's sucking up all the
bad money all the fiat money that's in
the world
it's like it's like a vacuum and it's
sucking everything up which is why it's
so volatile
so you don't want to use good money to
pay for things right now you want to use
the bad money and you want to save and
hoard at the good money
which is why most of the people who have
held bitcoin have held it on
for like years and they haven't moved it
does that make sense
that's what i think is going to happen
at some point it's going to be such a
collector
sort of deal where just people are not
going to want to let go of them no
what's going to happen is this what's
going to happen is after
all this bad money like all this good
money is sucked up by bitcoin
as the market cap increases this the the
price of bitcoin will stabilize
yes so this these these 90 50
fluctuations are not gonna be a thing
like a three percent five percent
fluctuations can be like oh my god
bitcoin crash you know
like the s p 500 if there's like a three
percent drop in the s p people like uh
recession you know that that's how it
works but once it stabilizes
then we'll start to use it eventually it
was more stable
than the stock market through like april
may and june yeah it was crazy it was
super stable is it like ninety one
hundred dollars maybe
plus or minus a hundred percent for
months for a while yeah yeah
but yeah so so with the bitcoin like
main btc the ticker symbol that is at 50
000
the bit that bitcoin not like bitcoin
cash that one is gonna start scaling
with something called
the lightning network which like in a
nutshell i'll try to explain it like
super simply
but it's basically like think of like if
gold is bitcoin
remember back in that history would
transact with gold but gold is heavy it
like
sucked right like nobody wanted to use
it because it's hard to divide
people would steal it so think of
bitcoin as gold it's like the base layer
one it's impractical
it's heavy it's expensive so we created
in this analogy a layer two and layer
two was fiat money
right so we attached a piece of paper
and denominated it in gold
that was base layer so you're with me so
far two layers
so that's what we used and so these
pieces of paper were way more efficient
so you and i can transact with these
pieces of paper infinitely
and then when we were ready we could
settle on layer one
so we would be like all right cool the
net transaction effect of all the things
we did
it equals this let's go get our gold and
then we would divide accordingly
that's what's going to happen with
bitcoin so we'll have lightning network
basically
where you and i can transact on this
second layer
infinitely instantaneously cheaply and
when we're ready
that transaction the net result of all
the transactions are going to get
settled
and then they get sent to layer one on
the blockchain and that's when we
resolve the transactions does that make
sense i've heard that was gonna happen
for years
that's gonna yeah it's been in the works
for a long time because it's a very
complicated
system to build um but that's one of the
solutions building it
it's the core team from bitcoin bitcoin
core yeah okay
that kind of sounds like robin hood
trading bitcoin
and it's exactly what it is yeah it's
derivatives that's right which is
one of the criticisms that the bitcoin
cash team had
their criticism was you're literally
recreating the current financial system
because who's to say that we can't just
print an
infinite amount of currency on the
lightning network right you have
literally that's true gotten rid of all
the fundamentals
of bitcoin because you're no longer
using that tech you are using another
layer that is not even connected to
bitcoin
just like we did with cash because we
got rid
of base layer one we got rid of gold and
now it's a free-for-all we're printing
infinitely who cares that's what people
are afraid is going to happen to bitcoin
eventually
that's a great point yeah is yeah we'll
go to layer two cool but then
who owns that who controls that who
prints that
like that's are you worried about the
government stepping in at some point
not at all why because they can't do
anything about it what are they gonna do
ban it to what extent say
that you can't it's illegal they they do
they pull like a china
they say you know what you're not
allowed to do this we're gonna block
websites
that uh that promote the buying or
selling or trading of these currencies
it's it's going to be fraud you know
impersonating the dollar
right and they're going to criminally
charge people right or like distributing
a certain amount
right i think if they did that there'd
be like chaos in the streets personally
but let's just say they got away with it
somehow banned it
the price would definitely drop
substantially but the truth is
where the us cripples it
switzerland or any other country that
wants the us's business
would double down and be like well these
guys are idiots if they're gonna get rid
of like bitcoin and all that business
come on in welcome so like the the way
the world works is like countries don't
just all unanimously agree to ban
something
countries compete against each other so
they'll never unanimously say
let's get rid of bitcoin does that make
sense like
easy example russia and the us they hate
each other where the u.s
wants to [ __ ] something russia will
say great come on come on in
we'll accept you but i don't think the
u.s will ever ban bitcoin because of the
opportunities that they lose i think
our government is not very smart but
they're smart enough to know
not to get rid of opportunities like
that so do you think they would just
create their own stablecoin
so that's what like people say is like
are you afraid that banks will create
their own
and it's hilarious because i remember we
talked to vlad tennef the robin hood ceo
and we're like well if do you think that
that crypto's the solution to robin hood
like we need to decentralize brokerage
and vlad was like no we don't need it
and i was talking to him too i was like
we really don't that's not the
like i'm the biggest crypto bull ever
but i don't even think that's the
solution the technology is not the
problem
because what crypto solves honestly is
security
and sovereignty that's what it solves um
and that that's not the solution that
necessarily we need
in this case with brokerages or with
like i don't know
banks creating their own because the way
that blockchain works
is it's very inefficient we are doing
like it's like a
root what do you call those gold rubric
gold machines oh
rube goldberg goldberg machines there we
go it's like a rube goldberg machine to
accomplish something you can do
instantaneously
if you just had a database a personal
privatized database which is what banks
are
so it doesn't make any sense for banks
to do blockchain they're trying to for
the hype of it
but they understand that it's
meaningless because the whole point of
blockchain is to decentralize it so to
have a private entity
decentralize something that is
centralized makes zero
sense because they have a rube goldberg
just to do it
it's like hey we're gonna do something
inefficient to do what we already do
but worse for literally no benefit to
anybody
got it so they will not create it in any
like realistic capacity
but what we will see that's crazy cool
if we do
was like libra from facebook people were
like i don't want my own life
facebook money i don't want that we do
want that
actually we would love that you know why
because if facebook creates libra then
tesla creates its own thing then apple
creates its own thing
and for the first time in human history
we can have a currency
that's competing on a
capital market like for the first time
money can compete
and it's never been able to compete our
governments have said
this is the money you're going to use
it's called fiat which means to rule by
decree
so it's like for the first time we have
the chance
like any product computers compete cars
compete
and we get the best products in the
world because companies can compete
against each other and give us the best
result
imagine yeah but what would be the
advantage that seems horribly
inefficient it would be like
having so many different currencies like
10 different currencies in my wallet
like all right
the end result that i'm talking about
isn't that i want like
tesla coin and apple coin that like
you're right that would suck
that's not the point that the point is
that once there's a lot of these
currencies out there in the market
they're because they're digital they act
as bridges
between the crypto world and our world
right now that's all they are they're
like temp bridges
so if we make it easy for people to on
and off ramp
from our fiat system to the digital
currency system that's what makes
crypto that much easier and more
accessible seems like it would be more
of a hassle though to get like
libra that i could spend on facebook or
tesla coin i spent a tesla
that just seems like a bigger obligation
i'd rather just stick with the dollar
sure and you can but there's lots of
countries in this world that are run by
corrupt governments who print money away
and now
they can't save money we could say that
because we live in a first world country
where we can have a savings
but these other countries they can never
be i guess
brought up to the first world because
they're not competing on first world
terms
they're competing in their own corrupt
government so if i'm in venezuela
and i'm trying to save money well
tomorrow my government printed so much
money that literally everything i saved
is worth half now
so i'll never be a first world country
because i'm beholden to that
so these benefits aren't necessarily to
us the first world
does that make sense kind of then why
wouldn't you just go to bitcoin and
create the lightning network or
something
equivalent to paper money over top of it
yeah it gets so complicated like people
are
we're all just trying to see like what
works from you know like let's make it
more efficient create another layer
let's create
different coins but the point is is that
we're entering this phase where like
we're on the precipice of democratizing
money
with tech which is like never happened
before everything we've created from
this
lamp to these cameras this couch that
companies compete with each other to
give us the best product
if we gave that opportunity for money to
happen what would we get
and so far we think it's going to be
bitcoin that's going to be like
you know the thing so how high can it go
how much things money am i the only
reason i'm watching this
is how high people just want to know
what price can they sell at
yeah there's this famous like hilarious
funny quote from the matrix have you
seen it
i've seen the matrix i've seen the
matrix remember um morpheus
i remember what's the quote yeah okay so
morpheus is like
uh or neo's like wait what are you
saying if i'm the one
i can dodge bullets and then morpheus is
like
no neo what i'm saying is when you're
ready
you won't have to and it's like this
hilarious meme in bitcoin
and the whole point is like oh i could
sell and become a millionaire and buy my
lambos
like no dude when bitcoin is ready you
won't have to sell it that's the whole
point
huh you don't have to sell it you use it
[Laughter]
geez that's why you're buying it you're
not there to use it yet
it's accumulating it's building it's
creating and while we're doing that
yes the price is going up and some
people don't get it and they're like
selling it trying to become rich with it
but the point is not to sell it for the
dollar the point is to get it to a point
where we're using it
behind the scenes and it like so why
aren't you investing more
i want to what's holding you back uh
things that i bought taxes taxes
yeah yeah too actually remember last
time i was on i had like
yeah you said you were nervous you could
be not a millionaire due to taxes
yeah i remember that you had a million
dollars in cash i did i
was hounding you to invest it back then
yeah and i was giving you crap because
you have more cash than me
yes but it's a smaller percent smaller
ratio it doesn't matter
it does matter let's say a million
dollars is two percent for one person a
million dollars is ninety percent for
another person sure the two percent i
wouldn't see is a big deal when you look
at the ratios
no you look at the the what do you call
it the
the cost opportunity cost of that money
so
yeah you could do averages or like
compare ratios but
the opportunity cost can also be like
put into questions so your
two or three million or however much you
had in cash is costing you x y z and
opportunity might be that's far
more than mine so you could look at it
that way but it's a smaller part of my
portfolio no but i think that
yeah you gotta think you guys are both
right yeah we're blindfolded yeah i know
i know
right it's it's a spectrum of being
right now more some infinities are
bigger than others it's
too much money to have in cash i think
we we agree with that yeah so anyway
what i was saying with that is um i i so
i'm going to pay my time i haven't yet
but
i will um so that's going to take up a
huge chunk of that so
after that after that podcast i think
like the highest i had in my bank was
like 1.7 or 1.6 in cash
and so i i'm gonna pay half of that
towards taxes
yeah and the other half i you know
you'll find out soon i hope
okay yeah that's exciting yeah that's
gonna be dope that's cool so then after
after
that thing that you did are you gonna be
putting more money into bitcoin
i want to yeah depends on like what it's
doing right
like if it's 100 what if it's just
shooting up
i don't want i won't have fomo like i
don't i have so much money in it that at
this point
if it goes to 100 grand i'm gonna be
like whatever
multi-millionaire or something like i
don't i don't have fomo in that regard
i bought ethereum at 200 a piece wow
this is crazy i have so much fun buying
it though but because it's trading all
the time like today the markets were
closed i was like
i could just go and buy some bitcoin
right i saw it it's like it
i don't know i didn't buy it today i'm
gonna hold off because i don't wanna get
carried away when i get into something i
start investing too much into it exactly
that's
i don't want to get carried away above
my one percent that i said
so for me it's like that's one of my
fears too is like uh
my bitcoin portfolio is over 50 of my
investments like
i love i'm a value guy like i love
dividends and passive income and
kevin o'leary is like we're basically
the same person yeah
except i've got more hair and uh no no
we're not
but you know he loves like cash flowing
companies
and like that i love that too but my
portfolio with
like dividend stocks is like 300 grand
and my bitcoin's like
700. why don't you up the dividend
portfolio why don't you get that to five
i'd like to i'd like to get it to a mill
okay and that way i want to be able to
make 40k off my dividends that's it like
that's without
my 40k i was like if everything
collapses and fails and i've like
youtube just
deletes me cancels me like i could still
live off of 40 000
a year and that's such a comfortable
salary provided how i live
yeah like i'm really frugal so if
everything goes away i could still live
off the interest of that plus with
bitcoin's interest
but i feel like you're doing that
already i'm already bitcoin the dividend
portfolio yeah for sure yeah but i still
just like to
up that a little bit like my ultimate
goal i think would get to at least six
figures 100 grand passive income that
would be so cool yeah
do you feel nervous uh or do you feel
like you're at the point where
you can kind of chill a little bit like
you you've been sure dude yeah
you feel like you've made it it's so
crazy like before i started youtube
you ever like wake up one day and you
have like this anxiety you're like
having a heart attack just me all right
well regarding
what which which no just just in general
have you ever woken up and you just like
have your heart beating you're like i'm
like nervous about but
you don't have anything to be nervous
about but you just are uh
sometimes usually that's for me when i
don't have a video planned out
well there we go yeah that's what it is
for me but like times ten
but no reason like i had that before
yeah
um and now that like i think i've i've
made enough money to even now if like i
disappear
which i don't want to but forever for
whatever reason that happens
i i'll be okay and that makes me not so
nice so was that a financial concern it
was a financial
concern for a long time got it yeah do
you feel like that graham
um yeah you know it was odd but like i
used to be so nervous about being
homeless i don't know
why or homeless where that came from
overcompensated by buying like
a half a dozen homes
no i don't know why i've just been like
i just didn't want to be homeless
it's it's weird live with your parents
at that point
yeah which it didn't make any sense like
i'd always have like some sort of family
member i'm sure
that would that would want to take why
do you think that is is it like
abandonment issues
i don't know why i don't think so you
got we got to get to the bottom of this
i would like that i don't know
i i think it's just this the comfort of
knowing that i'm i'm always gonna have a
roof over my head i feel like this is
transitioning into part two of our
insecurities
i'm just always afraid of being homeless
jack's like well i'm
we got quite a range here yeah body hair
to homelessness
what was yours again i forgot what yours
was
this is the same as mine yeah it was
probably similar to that no was it no i
don't feel did you say body hair i mean
remember i just
disclosed it you did i did but i forget
what
i forget what it is actually i think i
do know what it is
my fear for a long time was not having
better pokemon cards than graham
but what's crazy is no did you bring it
so last time we did this you had a
psychic energy here
yeah that you gave me right and i was
kind of upset because that was not what
i
really wanted i mean it's a cool car
yeah it's dope
i like it but i got this is from
graham's pack that you got from logan
paul
right which you spent what 12 000 11 11
000. but then oh this is it
i got i got this card which is the
second card that graham got from his
pack
wow that's the reason i see it
are you gonna do a trick you're gonna
yeah i'm gonna give it back you're gonna
i feel like you're gonna do trick with
it because i want the magikarp
yeah and then and then you
[Applause]
yeah so like my going into the pack i'm
like i'm gonna keep the holo card and
then donate the rest of it to charity
so i put it up on ebay and a bitter
spent like i think it was like 4 500
bucks on the rest of the car
a lot yeah it donated all of that money
to back to nami
but the one card i wanted to keep for
myself was the magikarp
because the magikarp evolves into a
gyarados and they both came in the same
pack
and i was like well i don't know oh man
see i just don't know if this would have
gotten
a psa 10. bro that looks like an 11 to
me oh it's so good
it really is perfect it's so perfect
oh man so psa tens on these cards
i think a grammy at this point no no no
it's sold for like
four or five hundred bucks i was bidding
on one of these on ebay on a psa 10 and
someone bit like a dollar more they
sniped it yeah they sniped it from me
but oh
man that that does look perfect the
bottom's a little bit
no it's pretty perfect this is pretty
perfect
what's crazy is it's kind of symbolic to
me
so the reason symbolic is because graham
got the gyarados
because he's like a really big youtuber
but
i got the magikarp because i'm the
underdog and i'm the littler guy
so you're the gyarados i'm the magikarp
you just got
you just got the tackle yeah damage i'm
kind of useless but
i try oh man one of these days i'll
evolve into a gyarados
of my very own and get myself a jacket
we also have another announcement
before we go back to the pokemon thing
uh we're hiring
we're hiring guys so if you want a job
come working for us you could be behind
the scenes
making sure the cameras are all working
okay and the audio's good
we uh we're we want someone to come and
join the team
but we had a bit of a controversy oh you
don't know about it i gotta hear this
what's the controversy
so jack and i this morning uh figured
okay we're gonna put together a video so
we
want what's my magikarp
where'd you take my magikarp i didn't i
see these two she's messing with me
bro bailey was jumping i saw bailey have
it in her mouth as she there's no way
no yeah nowhere there's no way dude
i mean seems like it but i i this is
like a magic trick
i don't know i swear to god i don't have
it what yeah i don't have it
okay i'm just going to cross my fingers
and hope that she did not take it
because i'm going to be very sad i feel
like this is one of those things here
it's like it's in your pocket
no and
we'll find it afterwards all right all
right all right anyway yeah the
controversy yeah
we're about to have another one yeah
okay
so yeah so the controversy this morning
we figured what's a good idea what's a
good way to hire somebody
well we think that they should upload a
video to youtube with the title graham
stefan interview
okay with reasons why they should work
with us right
and then we could pick the one who's the
most memorable and we feel like would be
a good fit to join the team
so jack and i this morning just riff off
on the camera
and winged it yeah and jack was like you
know oh
he's putting out like you know an
outline i'm like no no man let's just
wing it let's just get in front of the
gamer have fun
five minutes and upload the video
so jack wanted to make it very clear in
the video that he wants someone who's
willing to do a job like doing
jack's laundry no but let me let me
explain
so i'm not saying that like someone to
do the
laundry but i'm saying the kind of
person that would be okay
to do stuff like that right because the
sole purpose of this job is to give
graham and i
more time to be able to focus on you
know the graham stefan show
graham stefan and the podcast you sure
you don't need a girlfriend instead of
just an assistant
i would love a girlfriend that's been
unsuccessful so far so the next step
i just want somebody to hug me sometimes
you know so they need to be able to
kiss me sometimes just show me affection
just tell me it's gonna be okay
it's gonna be all right so the whole
the whole so yeah we said like the
laundry thing right and i don't mean
someone that's actually going to do
my laundry explicitly like that's their
job but i'm just saying someone
that will be here 40 hours a week or
whatever and just assisting us with
things
right and i would love someone that
would be willing to go so far
out of their way that would be willing
to do the most that they could possibly
do to help us and
yeah here's the thing for me it's like
my experience has been
when i first started working as a real
estate agent i worked with this guy
for free and i was doing everything
whatever he wanted me to do
i would go down and he'd be like i left
my checkbook in the car and it's like
five stories underground walk across the
street
go to my car bring me the checkbook
at 9pm at night i would do it i never
asked for any money doing anything if he
was like graham can you go to this
property and photograph it for me and
then photoshop the pictures and then
go and go and email i would do it yeah
that camera clicked off we could just
use these two for right now and then
we'll go back to the wide
uh i would do it no matter what it was
and i did that for
years now i started making money doing
my own leases but whatever he would need
i would do
even if he needed me to go and like grab
food for him
for you what do you mean was that
valuable was that a valuable experience
yes absolutely because in return for
doing that i got to be around someone
who
i learned from all the time i think that
for the first few years of me doing that
it was worth it
i would say after about three four years
i started to outgrow that
hmm i don't know why you're smiling i
mean yeah because all of this is leading
to
you need to be able to be okay with
doing the laundry no
no no no that was the thing you're
starting the controversy yes i gotcha
just hear me out when jack started right
i wanted someone to go through my
facebook emails sure and we had a the
millionaire real estate mastermind which
to get into the group you have to put in
your email address
and then i wanted someone to go in
manually and just copy copy copy and
admit the people into the facebook group
i tried paying people to do this because
it was such a just
horrible task and it's boring right and
i was paying people like 15 an hour can
you go and do this
everyone's like yeah man i'll get around
it would never get around to it paying
them
jack sent me seven emails in a row just
being like dude whatever you need
i'm willing to help you i just want to
learn and
it just so happened i saw jack's email
at a time where i was inundated with the
facebook stuff and i said hey man
if you really want to learn if you do
this that'll help me out a ton if you
just want to help me out
he did it in like overnight like the
next day it was done
didn't ask for any money or anything
like that and so to thank jack i'm like
how about i'll take you out for dinner
i'm just mad for dinner and that was it
and then jack was telling me over dinner
like if there's anything else you need
whatever it is
i i just want to learn and so he did and
he would help me out with the uh we did
the phone calls on the gram stefan show
we just started up the channel
and uh in the beginning didn't get paid
at all did you do your laundry
i didn't do the laundry but i literally
would have done
anything i would have gone and fetched
food for ramsay's like cleaned up
ramsay's
fecal match sure like in the house i
would have been so happy would you have
eaten
that's borderline eating a sea cucumber
but i literally would have done anything
and that was the whole purpose of like
the whole laundry statement right
is that we want someone that would be
willing to why do you say it's a
controversy did you get
no well we're getting there okay so
here's the deal i come
from somebody who'd like i would have
done anything for free jack
worked for free and now now you get all
self-conscious we talk about how much
jack is making six figures now the point
is i i worked for nothing and now i'm
doing well and the same for graham he
worked for nothing and now he's doing
well yeah
and even or we expect even on youtube
man
honestly like i worked for free on you
like that that first year i was losing
money making youtube videos i just
enjoyed it
sure we want the same type of person who
has the same type of enthusiasm that's
like
i'm willing to do it i will clean up
bailey's poop i will do jacks laundry
is that something you ask for is that
something you just spot in people
you know what i mean like do you maybe
you ask for that or you you notice that
you know what i mean maybe that's where
we messed up so here's the controversy
we mentioned in the video
tongue-in-cheek sort of like
jack's laundry and i'm like oh yeah
jack's laundry is bad you don't want to
do jack slime it's a joke yeah
and we kind of leaned into that and we
were just like you know and it might
include like
driving us around and like just doing
doing like
anything uh including maybe editing for
the podcast
shopping for lots of bleach
but but people in the comments went
awful like you're giving forty thousand
dollars
for somebody to do all these jobs and
like be your assistant to do your
laundry and be able to edit that's the
jobs like
that's two people's jobs you're asking
for one that's a
million you know a millionaire to start
doing that and i'm like
people send emails every day willing to
do work for free
right and we want to pay somebody to do
these things and grow with us over time
it's like when i first started i was i
was doing the jobs like three or four
people
it's it's like it's whatever you need to
do you got to get done so we were
looking for the same qualities but i
think we
we missed the mark on that by by
outlining something that maybe should
have been implied right
yeah i agree that's not something you
ask for that's something you notice
but yeah but we drastically need it
right now that's
true jack needs his laundry he is not
yeah oh my god
yeah yeah no i mean yeah like it's not
something you can put in like a job
description
it's just something you notice you're
like oh this person is really motivated
you know
but i think this is something that
graham and i both recognize i'm sure
you're very similar but like
you know you can sign up for a job that
does you know eight hours a day
five days a week but anything that you
do more than that
it just it will come back and benefit
you and i knew that like even if i was
making no money doing the work for
graham it's like
i know i'm confident in my ability to
provide value
and when i'm in a position where i have
a connection with graham i can think of
ways to
to make gram money and if i can make
myself a super valuable asset
to something i i you know in turn i can
receive some benefit i'm sure you're the
same way
yeah i make money from jack making money
like jack will come up with ideas
that will make him money that make me
more money
that pays for jack sure and jack makes
more money sure so it's like it's
it's a win-win for everybody and so p i
think some people just
are too short-sighted they're focusing
on like the right now
oh cleaning jack like honestly there are
people out there that would do your
laundry for free
just to go and like just just to go and
like be
introduced like that's what i don't get
same thing
people get upset at me for posting on
instagram like hey
i'm selling my iphone guys 400 bucks to
buy my iphone people like
you're rich you should just give it away
i can't believe you're selling that but
little do they know whoever comes by
first of all we get to hang out
they get a personal connection and
usually they get an instagram shout out
which which is probably worth like five
grand that they're getting just to come
and hang out
um and usually like the guy who picked
up the desk we gave him all free access
to the mentorship group which is 130
dollars
we gave him free access to that and we
gave him an insta or do we get to
instagram shout
out i think we did something yeah we did
we did do an instagram
and we talked to him on like a weekly
basis for him coming and picking up a 60
desk that people were upset at me at
right i know i can't believe you're
selling a broken
desk i can't believe you're doing that
donate it
we sold it for 40 dollars there's no
sympathy for millionaires it's just
that's just how the society we live in
but it's it's so sad that people don't
see the benefit beyond it
and oh here's here's the perfect example
the couch i sold the couch for dollars
and the dude was was telling us it's
like yeah now i didn't really do the
couch for 1800 i just did it because i
wanted to meet you
and get that connection and we still
keep in touch i mean it's just
it's one of these andy gets a couch at
the same cost that i know
that's
it's frustrating to me that people go
off on me on that and they just don't
get it i want people to understand
right but maybe that's something that
you just you can't that's the difference
between the one percent and the 99
that's true yeah
i think people were also upset because
they said we were asking for two jobs in
one
with like the laundry stuff like a maid
and then also someone who'd
be able to turn on the cameras like a
techie person but all they would do
is turn on the cameras and make sure
that they don't die when we're recording
a podcast and
i would teach them how to edit the
podcast which is also like a marketable
skill that
would collapse what's the starting
salary for people watching
40 40 000 yeah is that like a trial
period or like
that's just like the first year but the
thing is it's like they're not limited
to that
if they come up with another thing that
they can do like what if i say like hey
can i have you on a saturday to do this
or they say hey jack i have a great idea
for the channel what if you do this what
if they find me a sponsor what if they
were like yo graham
i've got a great idea will they have to
split it with you or split it with me if
they go straight to yourself absolutely
not no
well i mean that's a great question
because we're gonna have to discuss that
okay
it depends what it would be right yeah
but no my goal
would be that it starts at 40 but
there's room to grow beyond that like i
really want it like
i i hate the idea of bringing on new
people
and i want to get like one person and
just keep them forever
sure and just continue growing with that
person like with jack
just keep that going as long as possible
yeah
i mean 40k is a really good salary for
like an assistant and no college degree
no yeah like no education no college
degree
and i think we're just fun to hang out
with like this isn't like
we're not biased at all but no
it's like i i mean here i am saying it's
like it's doing difficult work
i just see it as being fun all the time
but they gotta like live and breathe
i think it's only fun when you're in the
driver's seat i don't think it's
no i had so much fun as an agent like
working for
just doing stuff for free for somebody
else i had so much fun doing that
yeah because the premise is for you
though the premise is ultimately for you
to build an empire
yeah but who's to say they can't build
their own empire well it depends right
like what's the job with you as an agent
you could
but if you're an assistant it's like a i
don't know if the trajectory is there
unless they assert that it's
true so i don't see it as like the same
fun
i would look at jack is the perfect
example of of you know jack being able
to use this to leverage into real estate
i don't think this is the same example
though
why because oh yeah that's true that's
true if jack just gets 10 years
at his current salary well not not
really a salary it's his current income
uh he'd be set for life all he has to do
for 10 years is just
not screw it up invest it three or four
years five years
true you think it's ten ten years yeah
ten years of just not screwing it up
just if he saves everything invest it
all for 10 years
he's set for life the rest of his life
for you to be a youtuber for 10 years
is like a dinosaur like it is so
hard to be an influencer for 10 years i
would disagree
i would say that i'm almost halfway
there
things are the not sure things are only
getting better and i think there's so
many new verticals
to expand to that weren't around 10
years 100 so i think
every year goes by it becomes more
solidified that you can do this
yeah that's true i'm not arguing that
but i'm just saying like in terms of
like
influencer years that's a really really
well i also think that your current job
will
open up plenty of other doors and
avenues in the event that your youtube
channel doesn't work out here's the
thing i've noticed too
is that it seems like a lot of the
youtubers that have burnt out a lot of
those
were channels that had been impacted by
an algorithm or channels that were like
like prank channels
yeah right i i think business is a new
niche that maybe
it suffers the same fate or maybe we see
all of a sudden the sec just cracks down
on everybody talking about investments
and
the algorithm shifts away i think that's
a that's always a chance yeah but i
think it's a it's a it's a niche that's
more akin to like a talk show host
right than it is uh a youtuber yeah no i
see it too
there's just a lot of risks but yeah
we'll see you're right there's a lot of
new verticals
that i've never expected but also the
connections that jack has made
i would say let's say that youtube just
disappears tomorrow
and i'm like listen jack we're shutting
it all down there's nothing here anymore
best of luck the connections to jack has
made a hundred percent
within a week you'd be able to find a
job earning
almost the same thing working for
somebody else
i don't think i would have to go back to
college no that's the no i'll put it
like
i i would just know three people off the
top of my head that would hire you
in an instant just if you're like hey
just i need a job i need a yeah
i would do it thanks
so that that's a way to look at it and i
think the same thing would also apply to
someone who's going in with 40k it's not
about the 40k it's about the bigger
picture
but you need to be the type of person
who's willing to do again you can't
talk about that people that get it get
it the people that don't will never see
it i guess so
yeah that's where we went wrong i was
very literal about like you gotta be
willing to do anything and giving like
just random examples but
i guess it's something that should not
be yeah i guess so people were upset in
the comments yeah yeah they did
i'm not gonna comment because i don't
wanna get canceled
i mean listen if this so far is our
biggest
controversy lately then we're doing all
right i think we're doing okay
um how's your video do today um
what was it it was a 10. no we could
talk about it man it was a 10. so for
those who don't know
when you post a video on youtube it
ranks it out of the top 10 videos
yeah like your last 10 like how did this
one perform relative to the last 10 you
did
a one means it's the best video of you
posted after lost 10.
yeah and a 10 means it's the worst you
never want to get a 10. because
especially as your channel is growing in
subscribers
like a 10 means it was even worse than
like how much did that ruin your day
this one i expected to get expected yeah
so i would say
it ruined my day like 25
normally if i did a video like this and
i was like it's gonna be a one and it's
a ten
that's like eighty percent like my day's
ruined i can't do anything afterwards me
too
yeah yeah this affects you like that as
well i'm so depressed for the rest of
the day
that's why you came in such a good mood
that's why you're like yeah yeah
what'd you have today two number two
yeah yeah it's good
i had a two i'm so happy about that
because i've been getting ones and twos
for like
same the last months same same for us
it's all been like
one two three three like if we got a
four once and we're like
the four is still equivalent to a one a
month ago yeah yeah it's cool because
as long as you're getting anything
between one through five
that means your channel has an upwards
trajectory yeah
this one i knew was going to get a 9 or
10 going into it because uh it was the
interview with idubbbz
and i knew that was not going to hit
with my audience off the bat so i knew
youtube was going to analyze that video
and be like all right
graham's audience is not watching it the
people who are clicking on it right now
are not watching it all the way through
so it's probably not going to be that
good of a video to recommend to graham's
audience
do you think that's going to get your
momentum uh no because my wednesday
video i feel like
is is going to be good enough to get
that audience back
i would never post two bad videos in a
row is it crypto related no
it's not no no no it's not
but i know my wednesday is good enough
to pick this up so i figured today is a
perfect day to post this because it's a
holiday
and typically what's happened with
videos like this is that
they'll do really bad for a week and
then all of a sudden the algorithm finds
let's see the idubbbz community and then
starts recommending it really heavy to
that
so michael reeves was the same thing i
think his video was a 10 by like
by like 50 percent so like the 9 was
like double a 10.
and i was really upset about that
because i i thought we nailed it on the
title and thumbnail
a week later within like three days got
a million views
same as the michael reeves one that we
posted on the second channel after a
couple days it was literally like
thirty percent of a nine wow it was
terrible
like literally less than twenty thousand
views in the first like four or five
days
which is wildly underperforming for the
channel but now it's two hundred
thousand plus
300 it's like three hundred fifty
thousand so that's easily yeah
that's one of those videos that just
consistently every day gets like a few
thousand views a day
it just had to hit with the correct
audience right so right now what youtube
is doing is it's saying like okay
graham's audience doesn't like this
video where could we show this video
where it might be a hit
so it's gonna test probably over the
next week and when it finds that vein
of just users like this are watching it
we're gonna recommend it to more people
that watch these sort of videos then
it's going to take off
under water what water of course yeah
i apologize for everybody the break my
voice is like disappearing
i still have a very soothing voice yeah
no it's not a soothing voice
how much did you make the entire last
year last year 1.8 mil
a little over 1.8 million oh a little
over that yeah
yeah that's more than i thought more
than you thought yeah you didn't watch
that video
no yeah you did a really good uh
breakdown
that videos thank you videos how many
how many views does that happen that's a
million
eight eighty one the irs has entered the
chat there's gonna be someone who's
commenting that
that's amazing yeah it's crazy but this
year i'm already over half a million
or like six hundred grand that's in
congratulations
two months what are you gonna what are
you gonna be doing with it all
right no but because i'm going into game
stuff but
like for the rest of the year do you
have a plan like an investing plan
of what you're going to be doing with it
just besides the usual consistent stuff
no so okay like dividends yeah
crypto yeah do you want to get super
wealthy
is that like something that you desire
like no
that was never like a huge goal of mine
just comfortable before my goal was to
get to fire
financial independence retire early
right which was to have just a million
and then make 40k a year passively that
was like the goal
and now that i've surpassed it i'm like
fat fire is the next goal
so for anybody who's not familiar with
sapphire is is 10 million five to ten
is that what it is so five to ten yeah
i've seen some where they say it's three
yeah i thought it was or maybe
yeah you're right like that would be
easy but then as soon as you hit that
then it's going to be
extra xxl fire that's what i'm afraid of
i don't want to always be that thing
there's like a proverb and i forget what
how it goes exactly but it's like
like a couple's walking down the beach
there's like a yacht out there in the
ocean
yeah it's like a billionaire yacht and
then like the husband and the wife and
she's like wow that's such a nice boat
he's like yeah but i'll have something
that guy will never have
she's like what's that enough oh yeah
i've heard that
that's so good that's deep it's like
that is so hard to do
in life to say when is enough enough
when do you quit and just enjoy life or
i know you're enjoying your work but is
there more to life than
working is there more to life maybe is
there like contributing back to society
is there
you know philanthropy is it like a
deeper meaning i don't know
but you haven't found what you enjoy or
a purpose like that yet
i think just like casey neistat did such
a great breakdown of this where it's
like we all as human beings have two
sets of problems in this world we have
the money problem
which is something we've all faced with
which is like
how do i afford rent you know where do i
live how do i pay for food and then
all of us have that problem but once you
solve that problem you get to the next
tier
which is something we all will forever
have what is the meaning of life
purpose love relationships like that
will never go away
no matter how many resources how much
money you have
so i don't know the answer to that
because i don't know if i feel like i've
conquered the money problem yet
and i i feel like i have like you
definitely have
yeah but i wouldn't quit i i love it i
think i think it's different for
everybody yeah
i love it too yeah it's not like about
quitting it's like
is are you fulfilled with life to this
degree or
or do you think there's something bigger
than what you're doing now i'm a hundred
percent fulfilled right now
yeah the only thing i'm missing right
now is the aquarium thank you you're
really i'm
so satisfied right i want for nothing
materially like i don't want tesla
no i don't even care like it's whatever
the only reason i want a tesla is
because
it's one of the safest cars on the road
and it's crazy because now that i have
money i'm like i'm
extra fearful about like lifestyle you
know what
you know what's crazy i was just
thinking that the other day i
i don't want to like ever jinx it by
saying that but like i really want to
live
i want to be like stop all the way at
stop signs it's like it's not
worth it that's my anymore to put myself
at risk on anything that might be
getting into danger
that's why fear is that once you get to
a certain level in life you accrue
this stuff this wealth whatever it is
resources
you start to become more conservative
and protect what you have
rather than take risks risks in life
and love in everything you stop taking
those risks because you're afraid of
losing what you have
and what you've built no i disagree i
think it's because you don't need to
take those risks anymore
i don't think you it's because of a
necessity it's because
you you want to protect what you have
which is why
i have this newfound fear and you have
it too no i just
i i enjoy life so much that i don't want
to do anything that would jeopardize it
like why take the risk that's literally
what i'm driving faster that's what i'm
saying yeah
yeah you don't want it to disappear um
so you know that's one of the struggles
is like well i don't know
do you want to live carefully or do you
still want to take risks i don't know
but like materially i feel fulfilled 100
and you don't elsewhere though what do
you mean feel fulfilled no i feel
fulfilled with love like i love
my girlfriend corey she's great but i
don't know
sometimes like you know if you're a
dreamer if you're an artist
you're just like oh there's something
more to life i don't know what it is
but i'm not saying i'm not happy where
i'm at i'm just saying
like maybe there's something more i
always feel that same way too like
like that i haven't filled the cup to
the brim yeah but i don't think
i'll ever feel that way i agree and i
think that
the closest that you can get to that is
by having kids
at least i'm banking on it because i
want you're 100 right i want to
know that you know what kids gives you
it gives you like my friend tyus talks
about this a lot he's great
um he talks about because like what he
lost his job he lost his wife he like
lost
all of his sense of self-worth right and
he was like on the brink of like
you know doing something bad and he
found the solution to it which was
purpose which is like if you have no
purpose in this world like why do you
exist
right so if you find purpose and meaning
then you'll always have a reason to find
your life fulfilling
and for some people that is kids for
some people that's a job for some people
like their cat their dog whatever um
so it's kind of an interesting
perspective yeah yeah so you've kind of
found
your purpose and your meaning just to do
what you're doing which is
we both find solace or like satisfaction
in helping people financially that's a
cool
that's definitely i think has given us a
huge advantage that it gives us
meaning to what we do um and it gives us
the other big thing which is recognition
and i think like as human beings we all
need
recognition for what we do without it
it's like
it's hard if you don't get praised
sometimes you're like hey you're doing a
good job
it's hard you know it's you need that
reward
so being in our position i think is one
of the most like fortunate positions
but you know sometimes i'm like you know
do i just do this forever until like
what
like i don't know is there an end goal
to this
do you travel the world i think i would
be feeling the same thing if it was just
like i got to keep making three
by the way want to hold the mic this way
this way yeah
yeah okay right there i think i'd be
feeling the same way if i was just like
i gotta keep posting three videos a week
indefinitely
but i don't know i feel like there's uh
there's so much more beyond that like
once it started getting into like angel
investing and then coming out with a
coffee thing and coming up with all
these other little projects
there's so much more that you could just
continually grow and evolve from
yeah but i just feel like all of those
things are tools like
those are experiences sure right like a
game that you got to figure out like a
little rubik's cube it's fun to solve it
but still those are those are just the
tools and i don't think that's the end
result
like i don't think i would be satisfied
if i just kept discovering more tools to
make me more money
like i know there's a fine
yeah for sure i'm not saying that it's
bad i'm just saying i don't know if
that's the end result
of what i think is the most satisfying
i'm not saying i don't want to go
through that because that's
that's why we're like starting you know
our group would be cool like how
you know are we gonna get to a hundred
million dollar evaluation create
products all that stuff's cool
but like i'm still i'm not like when i
look into the future of my life
i'm not seeing a chain of these events
over and over and being satisfied with
it i don't know if i see that
satisfaction
if i got 100 million like i'm just like
okay cool like then what
you'll find more ways but is that really
you just like keep
inventing new ways of making money and
that's fun i don't know
i don't know i haven't i'm not saying i
know the answer is right i don't know
the answer but
i don't feel like that is the answer i
think that everyone has their own answer
probably yeah yeah
yeah for sure do you what do you see
do you find yourself like being some
like billionaire and you're like alright
cool
no i don't think so not at all uh i
wouldn't pay that much
billy that's that's too much uh
i think that for me i'm more similar to
you
where i think like it's easier for me to
have like a simpler life
yeah and i think i would find more
fulfillment out of that and i don't
necessarily need
a bunch of money or anything i just want
to have enough yeah see for graham i
understand where he's coming from
i don't think he needs money because
part of the reason why we do what we do
is because it's like a game
it's like a puzzle and it's fun to keep
solving it and as a result we make money
so it's cool so for graham that's enough
this puzzle
it's like an infinite puzzle that is
never solved i get the appeal in that
but i'm just saying for me it i don't
know if
that's what i foresee my life being like
i i agree with you it's more about you
have any idea though
i i think when i thought about it for me
i do think it's about kids it's about
like family and just
maybe philanthropy maybe i'll feel
fulfill it because i love to do magic
and like cardistry for people and the
reason that i do
is not because people give me credit for
being like talented it's because i get
to live
through them the first moment that i saw
magic and when i see the joy and like
the
wow in their face i feel like i get to
live through that person
for the first time their reaction i get
to experience it myself because once i
know how a trick is done it's ruined but
when i see somebody else have that same
reaction i'm like oh my god
that's what it felt like and so
i don't know it's like i just feel like
there's more to life than just solving
an infinite puzzle that yeah
brings you money that's fine i'm not
saying it's not you need an aquarium
yeah you're right yeah i don't know i
have to say i've been so much happier
when i got the piano
i'll put mine in like 30 minutes
sometimes like 45 minutes a day of the
piano
once you get it yeah there's gonna be
something else right
the piano no once you get the aquarium
there will
be something else maybe i mean you want
maybe a bigger aquarium at some point
i don't know but there's this funny meme
or joke and i don't remember how it goes
but it's like
your happiness lies at the other side of
this aquarium
it's just like almost like trivial like
well obviously you'd be happier once you
get that aquarium
like that's that's the solution but like
yeah the reality is like you're never
gonna be happy but then we get like too
philosophical
where it's like i don't think we were
ever meant to be happy right
like what do you mean and elaborate like
we were never meant to be happy as
humans we're always on this like hamster
wheel of like chasing
what we think is happiness we have to be
because otherwise otherwise we'd just be
complacent
yeah nothing and then we would evolve as
a as a person
we'd all just be we'd still be cavemen
but that's what i'm saying so like with
you making money like
the reason i said it's just a tool so
you are stuck
in this obsession of the tool itself and
i've been there and like i know what it
is because i've done this with cardistry
with magical cinematography i've gotten
so involved
in the tool and perfecting the craft
that is the tool
to forget that there's a reason this
tool exists you leverage the tool to
tell it greater story than the tool
itself
yeah so for you it's like yes money cool
whatever companies products awesome but
those resources you can leverage into
something that is more meaningful maybe
no but but that is that is helping
people with financial literacy i i think
if i were doing something that were
destructive
right that would had a negative impact
on people even if i was making double
the money i wouldn't feel good about it
no no i'm not saying that i'm just
saying
do you find like like for me if i was
gonna go down your route of just let's
let's make as much money as possible
i feel like i wouldn't get enjoyment of
it until i utilize it but it's never
been about making as much money as
possible it's just been a byproduct
you're right you're right
loving it you know what i'm saying that
i mean that you're right but i'm just
saying
do you not like have this urge to be
like alright cool now i have all these
resources
how can i best leverage it to maybe make
use of it
that isn't necessarily for me because i
know it's not for you when i'm making
money yeah at this point it's like
whatever
but do you want to leverage it somehow
do you want to build something do you
want to
i'm still in the growth phase like i'm
not i'm not even there yet i still want
to continue growing
it no i'm waiting i'm sure at some point
it might change but i'm with you too
yeah do you think it ever will change
though
maybe maybe not but it's i think i think
as long as i'm as long as i'm happy
doing what i'm doing i think that's all
that matters
100 yeah i think that's true do you guys
think that animals are happy
yes yeah so you do you andre
i've never thought about that your dog
is for sure happy
yeah i think he's happy when i give him
like chicken right
right do you think that they're capable
of feeling happy
yeah of course so you think that the
whole happiness complex is just a human
issue
possibly why is that just because we're
like self-aware i don't think it's just
humans i think it's any evolved
species like i think monkeys are capable
of being happy
are capable of being unhappy i think if
you put a monkey in a cage
with no socialization that could be
miserable same same thing with dogs i
think with the right conditions they
will be happy
but i think some animals that are
capable of those feelings
would not be happy under those certain
conditions for sure yeah
i think if i was honest with myself i
think i'm the happiest that i've ever
been in my life now
like i've never been happy is it
happiness or is it being content
no i think it's truly happy yeah i don't
think i'm like content we all got the
same notification i'm just curious if if
you if we
yeah i need kevin he comes up in every
podcast
stimulus yep 1400. every podcast somehow
organically kevin comes up
and it's now become the running joke of
the channels like every podcast it's
like
when's kevin going to come up his second
stimulus update for the day
speaking of kevin jesus christ he's like
crushing it oh my god yeah kevin's a man
jesus i know his stock market portfolio
i'm listening to him
in one year it seems like he's figured
out the entire stock market
or he's gotten really lucky right but i
would say his analysis of stocks so far
has been really spot on right
i love his in-depth breakdown videos on
like uh i think he had one
on what was the car manufacturer neo
yeah maybe it was neo i love that video
and it got
i'm sure for him like a 10 out of 10 by
far but i love the video
oh yeah he picked it up so fast yeah
kevin's brilliant
and it's cool is that he has like so
much of a drive and a passion even at
his at this point yeah
and he has like a family and we don't
know how he does it because i don't
understand we see him on there at like
11 p.m at night
yeah still like going same energy and
then five a.m the next morning he's
honest
he was on clubhouse very very late yeah
it was like 11 00 o'clock
sleepy face emojis past midnight wow
yeah
he's not a sleepy face emoji he's like
oh this is boring
yeah meanwhile this is too slow for my
fast brain i know
do you think you suffer from
perfectionism yeah
it gets to the point where like i find
myself in a loop and it's been like two
hours and i'm like
i need to like go forward i i obsess
about a detail that i think
nobody would notice what like
um i'll do a take and i'm like oh that
didn't sound right i'll do it over again
and i'll maybe like be stuck for half an
hour on something that's a minute long
happens from not all the time but like
sometimes it happens and then i force
myself to get over it
um another time i'll be editing
something and i'll be like oh this is i
gotta add this i've become a lot better
at it
but when i first started it would take
me so long
to like edit or do something just yeah
it's crazy
i get this every now and then when i'm
trying to say one sentence but you start
saying it too often that you
mispronounce like
one word yeah that happens to me all the
time yeah but then i can't say it again
yeah it's crazy but like some people are
really gifted like kevin you could just
talk you just
watch the news yeah i know reiterate it
yeah that's amazing that's
that's a talent he'll make a great asset
i asked him i asked him if he's a
perfectionist at all and his answer was
just
no that was it just like not at all
not at all yeah no
kevin's definitely someone we all look
up to i'm sure yeah it's crazy i can't
believe i'm sitting here and talking
with you
like that's awesome why yeah because i
used to watch
watch you in 2019 you had like 300k subs
and i was like wow this guy's awesome
i'm sure he'll get to a million at some
point and then you took off
and i was like oh that's crazy yeah no
i'm taking it off no it's an honor to be
sitting here with you andre yeah
thank you but it's crazy the fact that
like you know when you want
like you were high dubs like the same
feeling it's like wow you still have
that there's no way you still have that
feeling not your old name
now you show up you're lazy let's get
this over with
i gotta get going
yeah no it's it's such a cool feeling
yeah and i
i don't take it for granted well we want
you on the podcast as much as possible
because these episodes do really well
and the conversations are amazing yeah
see i want to do once a month
where it's like you me and jeremy we we
invited kevin
kevin uh no on the podcast it's a
podcast episode for this yeah
with this yeah yeah because jeremy's are
so good because he really goes off on
like the stock market and the economy
sure and we lose i just listen i listen
to what he has to say on that
right but i think all of us together
would really get in like a good
rhythm on that for sure well which is
why we're making that channel
right millennial money that's right
that's gonna be epic i'd love to hear
people's like comments if if
anyone's left watching this video there
there will be people any ideas
yeah we get about 20 at the very end so
like 20 of the 20
on youtube but on like anchor like the
streaming services
it's a lot yeah it's it's like maybe
seven i would love to hear people's
ideas for what they would like for us to
talk about or do
because i'm sure there was a channel
like that already where like people take
risks
or like they compete against each other
for fun investments money challenges i
think money challenges that would be fun
like we should take a good grade
whether we started a channel that's what
it would be well there's literally a
casino that we go to
and we like see who can win more money
yeah or you know what are we going to do
that on your channel
i want to do that yeah so let's do
literally what i wanted to do yeah
you said you hooked it up with red rock
right so yes so whenever you want to do
it just let us know
okay and andre you you are onboarding
help at some point
i'd like to i want to start hiring i
just like i need somebody who's
a good editor who could do laundry no i
don't even know
laundry so so if you've made it to this
point
yeah and you want to make a video yeah
and a title and
you know entitle it and thumbnail it
sure and address andre
yeah preferably if you live in vegas
though because like i'd like to work
face to face yes
100 so i would need to meet them and
just like hang out and
you know i i think ideally at some point
we'd probably
like live with them because then you
have to
i can't like send footage it helps that
you guys are together all the time
well then you have somebody work from a
home office if they don't want to
necessarily live that's true that's true
which i have uh anyway
wow okay
no one's watching it anymore so that's
okay nobody's watching this no
i'm just gonna assume like 10 people are
left at this point
be lucky if it's 10.
anyway just kevin uh if you if you want
to pitch anybody to reach out to you
yeah i think it would be worth it yeah
sure how do i include my email
yeah you put it in the description yeah
yeah and my blog fight code too
yeah yeah sign up for block by yeah dot
com
andre would you would you actually hire
somebody i would really yeah okay that'd
be cool
what do you want them to do just editing
and shoot help me out
yeah you don't need help anything else
it's just like jack
yeah andre needs a jacket your name has
to be jack
yeah yeah exactly there was someone else
that we
reached out to earlier uh whose name was
also jack no and i thought it would be
so funny to get two jacks yeah that's
funny
be like jack i need your help you're
like jack too yeah
i would love i would like yeah
preferably if your name is jack
would be that's that's like an extra 10
points
10 points for gryffindor yeah yeah well
thank you
gotta be jack or macy would be really
funny too yeah thanks for having me man
thank you
is there anything else no i love you
guys thank you for watching and thank
you for watching my videos
definitely do you want to look for the
oh we should do the outro
uh ready yeah so andre thank you so much
for coming out
really appreciate it and guys thank you
so much for watching really
oh you know what you got to tell them to
smash like but look in that camera tell
them to smash like button
where did this come from i don't know we
were just talking normally he's like all
right we got to do the
track all right guys all right it gets
so high this is like energized like
where did this go let's destroy that
like button
hgh yeah all right um what was it going
to say smash like
destroy the like button for the youtube
background that camera right there
destroy the like button for the youtube
algorithm
please please subscribe please subscribe
and
get your two free stocks down below in
the description and uh go to block
fight.com forward slash andre to get up
at the 250 dollars worth of free bitcoin
when you deposit two million dollars
from the platform
[Laughter]
and otherwise you get a dollar i don't
know how much it is don't forget to get
those free uh
weeble stunks and check out my patreon
[Music]
call thanks so much thanks for having me
appreciate it
uh where's your magic where's the
magikarp
the magikarp
you guys aren't right
oh yeah so we're going to be starting a
joint channel at this between andre me
jeremy and kevin
what yeah why didn't you tell me because
it just happened when
now it's gonna be what yeah now yeah
it's like just
right now yes yeah
no yeah not right now yes yes right now
right now
this is the announcement video yeah
we've never talked about it
no no this is just hey graham you get me
way too much i'm not going to believe
this
i refuse to believe it i messed the jack
all the time show them the picture
yeah yeah did you guys see it i saw it
yeah yeah
that's just a meme no kevin made a whole
channel
and we're making banners like look at
that there's like different ideas the
other banner
yeah should we tell them what the
channel name is here uh yeah what is it
called
millennial money millennial money are
you kidding me
that's not the name of the channel it's
not millennial money yeah so great
is that not good no i think it's good
but it is uh
not super original but it's good yeah i
know it's good for seo yeah yeah
cnbc is going to have to change the name
now the nbc does not own millennial
money that's just their subheading right
right
but you know we looked at millennial
money channels
we're going to be the biggest one no you
guys
if you guys aren't are you serious yes
yes yeah we're going to meet once a week
for one hour yeah probably on tuesdays
yeah tuesdays i think it's six after six
and we're just gonna record a one-hour
video yeah
and we'll just talk and we'll do
whatever we'll do clubhouse too they'll
do it simultaneously so people can tune
in and ask us questions if they want and
it could be like a live
panel yeah it's meant to be more of like
a live panel sort of thing
oh so you're gonna have like people
asking questions and stuff like that or
we just
chit chat about whatever yeah huh it's
gonna be sick
yeah our goal nah this is just me making
stuff up but what
i was typing ever to everybody in the
chat room i was like yeah our goal is
gonna be a 100 million dollar valuation
in five years
oh that's that'd be sick yeah that's uh
yeah
we could do it we could do it yeah easy
easy
we're all gonna just invest you know
we're gonna be
young investors yeah
all this solid blue chip investments
that right
you know people like jack bogle john
bogle what approve of
yeah things like bitcoin yeah welcome
back to the 41st episode of the gramsci
ever
ever ever jesus christ very first ever
episode of the iced coffee hour my name
is andre and so far the podcast is made
this is a lot harder than 40 thousand
dollars
[Music]
when i'm pressured i can't do it all
right what was i saying again welcome
back to the 41st
ever episode of the iced coffee hour